l'irlande vous connaissez cette à droite
en sortant de l'amérique ou à gauche est
loin très loin de l'angleterre
elle n'est séparé de l'amérique du nord
que par l'atlantique
elle est séparée de l'angleterre par
tout le reste
l'espèce de défense anti char que vous
apercevez sur la plage immortalise
l'exploit des deux aviateurs américains
alcock et brown qui furent en 1919
les premiers survolé l'océan c'est ce
que dit le monument c'est aussi ce que
dit la légende et la légende mémoire -
courte que l'histoire qui semble avoir
oublié l'événement
nombre d'irlandais découvre l'amérique
chaque année mais il arrive de temps en
temps qu'est la suite dalle coq brown en
américains découvrent l'irlande qu'elle
le metteur en scène john huston qui
après avoir fait plusieurs fois le tour
du monde pour les besoins de son métier
a décidé un jour que la terre pour lui
finir est en irlande il y à trouver à
l'entendre la beauté et la paix plus un
château qui errait dans la langue de
galway plus un cheval pour lui un pour
sa fille et autour d'eux à perte du des
immensités verte sans usine sans fumée
est entièrement consacré aux activités
chlorophyllienne et silencieuse de la
photosynthèse
la beauté et à people les seuls êtres
vivants qui se permettent des rails et
la sérénité du paysage sont les oiseaux
du ciel de toutes espèces et de toutes
provenances qui par myriad ont pris tout
comme john huston et probablement pour
les mêmes raisons la décision de ce
pauvre une fois pour toutes sur l'une ou
l'autre des îles de la côte occidentale
que les irlandais leur ont abandonné
sans combat par amitié pur de gré à gré
d'être libre à être libre
le reste est silence de rester si
l'avancé pour le reste la première avec
la population locale et principalement
faite de pêche les pêcheurs irlandais
ouvre rarement la bouche crâne la vallée
du célé et la deuxième est qu'ils ont
pour fond panier habituels les huîtres
de pleine mer qui n'ont pour ainsi dire
pas de conversation elles sont
d'ailleurs excellente et c'est par
milliers par millions qu'on les envoie
en europe
ou quand les gogues sur place en les
arrosant de bière brune brune seulement
la blonde dénaturerait heures ça va
on
après la dégustation des huîtres à la
guerre le pays tire ses jouets les plus
saines
il n'y en a d'ailleurs pas d'autre de la
course de chevaux sur de beaux
hippodromes que la douceur du climat
interne est blessé rouvert d'un bout de
l'année à l'eau
en cours galon et depuis le début du
xviiie siècle et il est convenu qu'on
n'arrivera jamais
en
où
boncourt pour courir et quand on a bien
couru bien joué bien perdu on va voir au
château d'ashford s'il ya encore des
fantômes à et corridas magnifique
construction médiéval remanié
quelquefois par l'art militaire
désoeuvrés en ces lieux paisibles du
château d'âge ford a été livrée intact
avec ses tours ses fossés ses ouvrages
avancer son donjon sa peau terne il
reste l'armé des touristes qui tient
résolument garnison qu'elle n'est pas
près de se rendre
ce soit une erreur de croire que
l'irlande parce qu'elle est attachée à
ses traditions et qu'elle ne voit pas la
nécessité de modifier tous les matins sa
manière de vivre ignore tout des
inventions du monde moderne
elle préfère toujours le cheval au
moteur c'est vrai mais elle a tout de
même adopté le pneu comme on peut le
constater devant ses roues le rétameur
ambulants qui pour n'avoir plus grand
chose à rétamer non poursuivre par mois
leur interminable tournée de chemin
cahoteuse en route nationale peut-être
avec l'espoir discrètement humoristique
d'attacher une casserole avec du siècle
on
en tout cas si vous allez en irlande à
un mot est à rayer de votre vocabulaire
et c'est le mot passé il n'a là bas
aucun sens
l'histoire ayant été depuis longtemps
vaincu par la légende seul existe le
présent et sous le ciel floconneux
l'éternité symbolisée par ces croisés
monument celtique inusable ou par ces
oratoire de pierre qui depuis plus de
mille ans ménage dans l'épaisseur du
monde la cavité fraîche de leur abri
spirituel
pourquoi les irlandais échangerait qui
leur indestructible éternité et leur
présence et de vie simple et laborieuse
dans les espaces privilégiés que la
nature leur a concédé contre l'avenir
chargé de fumées industrielles et les
concentrations urbaines que nous promet
la société contemporaine
la liberté n'est pas seulement et bien
fait politique
c'est un état d'âme une disposition du
coeur irlandais libre pourquoi
changeraient thème
pour vous
pour